it took me a long time I've been acting
37 years because I was not successful
but consistently acting mainly doing
Theater in Chicago I never really
claimed being an actor it wasn't until
probably about 15 years ago that I felt
like you know I'm an actor and a certain
sense of of coming into my own being the
person that I was becoming and owning it
and um Marty was incredible you know I'm
in Chicago I'm too humble I'm just happy
to be here and stuff and he's like no no
you're here for a reason stand up be
proud put your chest out what do you got
there in the notebook and I'm like oh I
just wrote the backstory for this
character he goes read me the whole
thing so I ended up reading Martin
Scorsese three full single line College
ruled pages of my backstory of my
character it made me feel really good
and important and I'm grateful super
grateful to him and it's kind of a that
was kind of really a starting point for
the rest of my career
[Music]